[Inaudible].
Political and diplomatic relations between the United States and the people's
Republic of China have not been at their best in recent years.
So far in 2020,
multiple events have brought this kind of confrontation to the field of economy
and big finance. You don't have to look far to see news stories like this.
August 7th, 2020 Trump takes aim at 10 cents.
We chat in escalation of anti-China campaign,
us companies given 45 days to stop dealing with messaging app.
Not only that,
in addition to freezing the activities of these two popular applications in the
United States or lesser activities in the country,
transfers to companies that are not under the jurisdiction of China,
the raging war goes much further.
The Trump administration.
Is leading an entire campaign to tighten surveillance over Chinese companies
listed in the United States.
President Trump has even gone so far as to mention a possible financial
disconnection. If Beijing does not agree to change its rules of the game,
Just about the white house on the 21st of April,
the securities and exchange commission,
the body responsible for regulating the stock markets issued an alert,
a warning about the risks involved in investing in emerging markets,
especially in China because of the regulatory deficiencies that exist.
Emerging market investments entail significant disclosure, financial reporting,
and other risks remedies are limited as a result in many emerging markets,
including China,
there is substantially greater risk that disclosures will be incomplete or
misleading. Sec.
Then.
Shortly afterwards, in the same vein,
the United States Senate approved the holding foreign companies accountable act
by a large bipartisan majority on 20th of May, 2020.
It's a law that States in a cautious manner.
They're Chinese companies listed in the United States that do not comply with
the requirements of the accounting oversight board.
For us listed companies will be expelled from U S markets. Yes,
that's what I said. Expelled.
If Chinese based companies want to be listed on the stock exchange or access to
the U S capital markets, we must make them comply with us laws. If they do not,
we must remove Chinese base companies from us, stock exchanges, mucker, Rubio,
Republican Senator from Florida.
In other words,
if things do not change this law could ultimately lead to American stock
exchanges, expelling Chinese giants like Baidu, a Google style search engine,
or even Alibaba.
Because.
You see the law introduced by Republican Senator John Kenneth and Democrat.
Chris van Hollen requires that Chinese companies listed in the United States
certify that they are not under the control of the Chinese government and comply
with the supervisory standards that are customary in the country,
because the truth is that until now such bodies,
such as the sec or the accounting oversight board have not been able to access
the accounting and audit work on these companies simply because the Chinese
government does not allow it.
Beijing considers this kind of material to be state secrets.
This means that supervision and scrutiny of Chinese companies has so far been
much weaker, even if they were listed on United States, stock exchanges.
And there's even.
More agencies such as the federal retirement savings investment board,
which manages the retirement savings of governments and military employees.
We're talking about around $600 billion have decided to freeze their plans to
invest in Chinese.
Stocks.
May 13th, 2020 federal retirement fund.
Holt's planned China investment under pressure and Y times.
However, let's not fool ourselves. In spite of everything,
it is clear that the man of Chinese market is a tasty and appealing carrot,
not only for the big multinationals, but also for investors all over the world.
China carries increasing weight in the world economy.
That is why in this new installment of the series we are doing in collaboration
with value school, we are asking the following questions,
how much influence does the Asian giants really have in the boat of finance?
Why are us regulators alerting us to the risks of investing in Chinese
companies? How could those risks affect world finance? What are these risks?
[Inaudible].
In this video, we want to answer all these questions.
And we are also going to give you many details about some of the latest cases of
extensive fraud committed by Chinese companies. Some of which by the way,
are even listed in the United States stocks.
These are fraud cases consisting of a systematic falsification of company
accounts to build up an image that had nothing to do with reality.
Have you heard, for example, of Luckin coffee,
the great Chinese company that was to rival Starbucks? Well.
Let's get into it.
He's Chinese and more Chinese.
Everybody. Everybody wants a piece of China. We're talking about a huge market,
almost 1.4 billion consumers,
a middle class of over 600 million people and a purchasing power that just grows
and grows and grows. China is a huge opportunity to make billions in profits.
[Inaudible].
Now the question we can ask ourselves is from the point of view of financial
economics, how exactly are things going? Well,
the truth is that despite all the drums of war that we've been hearing lately,
things aren't going badly at all in 2019,
Chinese regulators began to relax many of the restrictions that prevented
foreign players from participating in the financial industry. And since then,
well, let's just say that the sector has been a veritable party,
a nonstop party,
check it out between 2019 and 2020.
We have seen PayPal acquire 70% of the Chinese company.
GoPay thus becoming the first foreign company to provide online payment
services. In China.
We have seen Goldman Sachs take a majority stake in the securities firm with
which it operated in this country. Exactly the thing Morgan Stanley did,
then JP Morgan has started to operate a futures company with 100% foreign
capital and American express has received approval to become the first foreign
credit card company to launch land-based operations in China,
visa and MasterCard are now following in the same path.
Even the rating agencies,
SNP and Fitch have been approved to perform credit rating services in the
country and dear friends of visual politics. These are just a few examples,
despite the constant rumblings of eminent war China's financial integration has
accelerated over the past two years. And if we think about it for a moment,
it's nothing unusable China's potential market is so huge that international
companies could make billions in profits by taking even a small share of it.
But it is not just the financial services industry.
The truth is that capital flows,
especially those known as portfolio of investment,
that is financial investment flows that do not involve taking control of a
company such as minority shareholdings or the purchase of debt securities are
growing substantially year by year.
Yeah.
You can see from this graph, by the end of Q1,
2020 foreign investor ownership of Chinese stocks and bonds exceeded 4 trillion
Yuan, about $600 billion,
a number that is expected to grow very strongly over the next few years,
as large companies that produce the best known indices,
such as MSEI are gradually increasing the weight of Chinese listed companies in
their indices. Let's take a look.
MSEI increases weighting of China,
Asia shares in indexes to 20% rich, all things considered.
It makes a lot of sense because the Chinese capital markets is getting bigger.
For example, take a look at this other group.
[Inaudible].
As you can see,
the Chinese stock exchanges are already the second largest in the world in terms
of the market value of their listed companies. And yes. Okay. You got me.
It's true.
Although this chart prepared by asset manager Alliance Bernstein includes the
Hong Kong stock exchange. The truth is that if we exclude that data,
the chart wouldn't change much.
And obviously that means that more and more international investors are going to
set their sights on the Asian giants capital markets.
After all it is precisely here that many business opportunities are emerging as
well as many of the new unicorns. And that's not the end of it.
Then we also have to take into account that there are almost 230 Chinese
companies listed on the NASDAQ and the New York stock exchange.
We're talking about companies like Alibaba, Neo,
or Baidu known as the Chinese versions of Amazon Tesla and Google
retrospectively. In other words, the Asian giant is not only,
only present in industrial and commercial markets,
but it's also increasingly present in the financial world.
And it doesn't really seem like that's something that can be reversed,
but so what, why so many warnings and misgivings,
why has the U S given the green lights to a bill that could end up driving many
Chinese companies out of the us stock exchanges?
Why so many sec warnings about the risk of investing in the Chinese capital
markets? Well, let's take a closer look.
A rampage announced.
It is clear.
Events have shown us very clearly that both the corporate governance and the
legal system in China are weak in preventing and dealing with all kinds of
corporate fraud. And that,
that has meant that fraud and accounting manipulation scandals in Chinese
companies are not something strange.
The latest big scandal occurred in the company known as the Chinese Starbucks.
Have you heard of login coffee?
Well pay attention because the story is not to be missed lucky and coffee.
It was launched in 2017 with one objective to popularize coffee consumption in a
country where this product is still very unpopular to give you an idea in 2018,
the annual per capita consumption of coffee in China was only six cups compared
to more than 200 in Taiwan and almost 400 in the United States. However,
Lukkin had a plan to offer cheaper coffee through stores in busy places to
achieve this. They developed an application to order and pay for orders,
which would allow the company to reduce labor costs on the one hand and on the
other to continually send customers new offers, gifts,
and discounts so that they would come back again and again and again,
and take notes because just one year after its inception,
this company received a significant capital injection from joy capital,
the largest venture capital fund in China,
and also from Singapore sovereign wealth fund,
the operation value to this startup at $1 billion with a new capital lucky and
began to grow at full speed. In just two years,
it opened more than 4,500 stores throughout China on may 17, 2019.
It's made its debut on the NASDAQ. Come on.
This company seems to have it all.
It was growing at full speed rather than Starbucks in the Chinese market.
And it had an app, an app. And do you know what that means?
Even though it was just a company that sold coffee,
it suddenly became a fully fledged technology company.
And so this is how it stock market debut became a huge success.
After the opening bell was rung lock-in shares jumped almost 50% from the
initial offer price. And in the following eight months,
the share price practically multiplied by three friends expectations for this
company were sky high.
November 13th, 2019 in sales top forecast,
as it chases Starbucks in China.
December 2nd, 2019.
China's Luckin coffee matching Starbucks at its own game logins.
Digital focus is shining according to one analyst that poses a particular threat
to Starbucks is China business. Jan, 17 of 2020.
This coffee upstart could be a stronger growth stock.
Then Starbucks in the near term says Gina Sanchez,
founder and CEO of investment consulting firm Chante co global.
At the end of January, 2020, the scandal broke muddy waters research.
A private investment firms specializing in short sale was published an 89 page
report. Apparently showing how this company Luckin coffee was systematically
misrepresenting its financial statements, especially its turnover.
The report stated for example,
that the so-called Chinese Starbucks was inflating.
The number of products sold by 60 to 88%.
Each the company initially denied it.
But finally on April 2nd had to admit that all the accusations were true.
Of course, as you can imagine,
the stock price automatically plummeted between February and the end of June.
When the NASDAQ expelled this company from their market,
it shares lost 95% of them.
[Inaudible].
They were aggressive and expanded very quickly either.
They got people to drink coffee and they would make a lot of money or it
wouldn't work when big or fail fast, a very reasonable strategy. However,
when I visited their stores, they were empty.
There were simply no customers while Starbucks across the street were full
Jeffrey Towson professor of the MBA program at Peking university.
That the lucky and coffee case was no exception. Over the last few years,
scandals involving Chinese companies have been frequent as of 2022 other Chinese
companies listed in the United States, the online training company,
talent education group under the streaming video platform,
Ikea have been linked to or admitted to alleged fraud. And in large part,
this is what explains both the sec warnings and the new legislation passed by
the Senate. So the question we can now ask ourselves is what now,
what consequences can we expect? Okay,
let's take a look on Kong style.
New legislation passed by the United States Senate and the growing hostility of
the Trump administration has set off alarm bells in many Chinese companies.
The most likely scenario is that eventually China will give in on this issue and
it will strengthen its control over corporate governance and allow us regulators
access to the accounting and audit working documents of Chinese companies.
But of course,
we're talking about a probable scenario or to certain one relations between
Washington DC and Beijing are becoming increasingly tense.
So the affected companies are putting contingency plans in place that basically
involve preparing for a listing on the Hong Kong stock exchange.
This is a path that has already been taken by companies such as Alibaba,
jd.com and the video game company net ease among others.
Then for its part China's largest semiconductor company for semiconductor
manufacturing,
international corporation even left the New York stock exchange and is now
listed only in.
Hong Kong in total.
According to the investment bank, UBS,
at least 42 companies listed in the United States now have plans to start
trading in Hong Kong as a preventative measure.
And that's not all in the face of so much uncertainty.
It seems that Chinese companies that want to go public are thinking very hard
about whether to use American markets at all.
The most famous case is undoubtedly that one of the,
the most valuable unicorn in the world friends group is a financial technology
company associated with Alibaba,
which is also one of its largest shareholders and which among other assets
controls.
Ali-pay the dominant mobile payment platform in China with more than 500 million
users, to give you an idea of what we are talking about.
According to existing estimates,
it could go public with a valuation of approximately hundred billion dollars and
friends.
We're talking about a giant that from what we can gather has decided to discard
the United States for now and has opted to go forward with listings only on
Shanghai and Hong Kong stock exchanges.
Well.
That's the way it seems.
Although China's financial ties with the rest of the world are steadily growing.
Everything points to the fact that in the near future,
as far as Chinese companies are concerned,
we will see Hong Kong playing a greater role than that of American stock
exchanges. Yes,
it's the financial center of Hong Kong that may benefit most from this new clash
between China and the United States. In fact,
in an upcoming video here on visual politics,
we will tell you how important Hong Kong remains for China.
And for the time being until things change,
you have to be aware of the additional risks that can come with investing in
Chinese companies. In fact,
this is one of the reasons why these companies are often quoted, for example,
lower P E R levels than their Western counterpart.
With this video,
we wanted to bring you closer to the growing role that China has in world
finance and the risks that this poses risks that we can never lose sight of if
we're talking about investment. But the question is as an investor,
what do you think of Chinese companies? Do you consider them,
do you think they are worth the risk or not
Answers in the comments? So I really hope you enjoy this video. Please hit,
like if you did, and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast they
provided the Vogue was in this episode that weren't mine. Also,
this channel was possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing
independence, political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.